beaucoup de choses à voir et entendre
pendant cette semaine de la presse à
l'école c'est l'occasion pour nous
d'inviter des lycéens aujourd'hui c'est
le lycée jean marc boivin de chevigny
saint sauveur avec jade et mac mini qui
sont avec nous et marie amélie a comme
mission de nous présenter une chronique
aujourd'hui c'est sûr précisément la
maigreur des mannequins pourquoi avoir
choisi ce en quelques mots parce que le
nom de la haute couture m'intéresse le
monde du luxe la mode des vêtements
termine que je trouve très intéressant
c'est une taille 36 maximum c'est ça oui
allez vous avez quelques secondes pour
essayer de nous intéresser à cette
maigreur des mannequins on vous écoute
tous donc pour devenir mannequin
aujourd'hui il faut correspondre à des
critères physiques très exigeant il faut
faire une taille 36 maximum et mesurer
au minimum 1 mais 2 72 donc pour cela
les mannequins à elles font souvent des
régimes du sport elle jeunes aussi donc
c'est pourquoi leur imc est souvent
inférieur à celui qu'elles devraient
avoir il aime c'est ça veut dire indice
de masse corporelle je savais comment
calculer mc a alors moi je me suis
renseigné auprès d'auriga jour dans la
diététicienne qui passe nous rendre
visite de temps en temps c'est diviser
son camp qui loue par la taille en
centimètres et on fait le carré tout ça
voilà puis si on a un gros chiffre mais
c'est que ça va pas très bien sûr un
petit chiffre c'est que ça va mieux pour
vous ça va très bien je vous laisse
continuer et donc certaines mannequin en
témoigner elle disait qu'elle était en
état de famine mais qu'elle était comme
applaudie lorsqu'elle arrivait encore à
perdre du poids et des témoignages de
mannequins par le biais de livres aussi
il ya une mannequin victoire masson
d'auxerre a témoigné dans son livre
jamais assez maigre elle dit qu'elle
était tout le temps en régime qu'elle
mangeait trois pommes par jour 3 pomme
par jour
lesquelles
elle devait elle critique le
comportement des créateurs qui selon
elle utilise les mannequins comme des
cintres
lvmh et kering qui sont des marques ou
millions aucun des grands noms du luxe
après plusieurs excès avec la maigreur
des mannequins ils ont décidé que les
mannequins devait avoir un suivi médical
qui attesterait que le serait pas trop m
et puis il faut savoir qu'il ya une loi
qui existe un mannequin depuis le 5 mai
2010 oui cette loi elle vise à lutter
contre la maigreur des mannequins donc
les marques doivent
mentionner lorsqu'une photo a été
retouchée sinon elle risque une amende
de 37 mille cinq cents euros
et elles ne doivent pas à recruter des
les agences de mannequinat ne doivent
pas recruter des mannequins de moins de
16 ans ou des mannequins qui font moins
que du 34 ouais ben oui cet objectif
cette loi elle vise à protéger les
mannequins contre la maigreur extrême
mais parce qu'avant dans les défilés
parfois il ya des mannequins qui
s'évanouit c'est un oui lors des fashion
week parfois des mannequins
s'évanouissaient parce qu'elle n'avait
pas mangé depuis longtemps mais lors des
prochaines fashion week les mannequins
et devront avoir un certificat médical
datant de moins de 2 ans qui attestera
que leur imc n'est pas est suffisant
donc je trouve que cette fois mannequin
elle est très bien pour protéger les
mannequins et les jeunes filles de
l'anorexie même si je trouve qu une
taille 34 36 ça reste assez petit pour
quelqu'un pour une mannequin qui doit
être très grande ouais et les mannequins
qu'on nous montre sur les défilés de
mode ou ou dans les magazines ça
représente pas vraiment les femmes
réelles parce que dans la vraie vie
toutes les femmes ne sont pas
extrêmement grande extrêmement m puis la
mode c'est pas que des vêtements c'est
surtout des femmes qui les portent des
hommes au style parfois oui oui donc ça
c'est très très important oui eh bah le
fait de voir que des mannequins
extrêmement maigre ça permet pas
forcément de s'identifier aux vêtements
et donc ça peut créer une sorte de
frustration
bah merci pour cette jolie chronique en
ont été captivés alors je précise que le
lycée jean marc boivin en ce moment vous
êtes en seconde médias prépare aussi un
journal en quatre langues c'est ça oui
quatre langues quelles langues italien
allemand anglais et espagnol bon on va
retrouver en france